[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you hear me now much much better all
right so where we were was that our boss
looked at our 40 lines of code that we
were you know inordinate ly proud of and
said well how do i how do we maintain
this right what does it work in this
condition or maybe we're not seeing the
performance of the recommender that we
thought we were going to get and so
after you spent all this time reading
this paper you finally go out and you do
that Google search that you probably
should have started with and you're like
oh man this is actually already in a
library and one thing that's great about
the Python community and the open source
data community is that if it's not in a
library yet it probably will be soon so
it's going to just be like a waiting
game for your boss and you notice that
you know this is in sort of an estimator
form right and now that 40 lines of code
that you had written becomes three lines
of code right you import the model and
you fit it right maybe put some hyper
parameters into it and you're like man
this is great and you go into the
documentation and you're like heck
there's a ton more other models that are
very similar to to what I was doing in
this case you know the this is maybe an
older story about the Netflix prize with
a recommender model using matrix
factorization but look at all these
other tools that we can use to do
decomposition or you know maybe today
we'd say in PI torch I want to use this
temporal convolutional network and then
you go into the PI torch documentation
and you see you know CN NS and RN n s
and LS teams and different architectures
and like oh man there's all this stuff
that I can try and so now you are the
hero right your boss is like this is
awesome we don't have to maintain it
performance is great we can build this
into our applications right everything
is going awesome and this is great news
and it's why I think that you guys are
all here at this conference right that
this makes it possible and you know what
I tell my students and and what I know
is that this is made possible by this
API right this estimator API where
estimators are objects that
learn from data we might have
transformers that applied mapping
functions to our data that learn from
data about how to routinely apply those
transformations or we might have models
that make predictions we can put them
together in pipelines and we have a sort
of a mechanism that the software
engineering team also enjoys using and I
think it's natural when you look at this
well and and one thing also another
great thing about this API is that that
academic work that we saw at the
beginning that digging through the paper
translating lots of math right you can
do that as a contribution but generally
speaking the algorithmic design stays in
the hands of academia and they're really
good at it right there's a lot of great
transfer from University out to the open
source community and then you get to be
this wizard right when you apply it in
your real work and I think that the
instinct is then to ask yourself well
can I automate this workflow and you
know given the number of products that
exist to automate this workflow you know
some of which have been presented in
this conference I think that this is
like the natural instinct and to a
certain extent you can formulate this as
a search problem a search problem
composed of the model selection triple
right we hypothesize that there exists
some combination of features right an
algorithm or model and it's hyper
parameters that modify the behavior of
that model in the data space and in the
model space that will perform the most
effectively in the application that
we're trying to put together and that
hypothesis is a strong hypothesis and
it's one of the reasons that we are
professionally competent that we can
move forward and it leads us down the
road of stuff like this where we just
grab our nice cross validation library
right we fit we do our cry folds cross
validation we fit we take the mean right
we look for the best scoring model and
we get into this mentality where it's
like just try them all see what works
and you know what I'd like to tell you
is like I'd like to say that this is
what you know my students do right they
don't know about these models so they
just try them all but I am happy to
admit to you and I guess you know
everyone in the world that I do this to
right like if I'm confronted with a data
set that I've never seen before
I have no idea if there's a linear
effect a nonlinear effect I don't know
what's in it so I'm very happy to spam
like eight AWS extra large instances I'm
just blowing away some search right just
to like get me in the right like
neighborhood right in the right right
ballpark but that story sort of hints at
the overall problem and that's that this
search play search space is not only big
but also infinite right so if you even
just ignore the feature set and the
algorithm said if you just look at the
hyper parameters for a single model
right your instincts to put a grid
search together even just for like a
simple text analysis with just a
two-step pipeline of vectorization and
then you know an SGD classifier some you
know stochastic gradient descent your
instinct is that as you increase this
grid of these different combinations of
hyper parameters you don't you're
getting into this sort of exponential
explosion of possibilities and this is
just one small corner of the algorithmic
landscape and so at this point maybe you
start to feel not so wizard because that
earlier wind that you got by reading
this paper about the specific
application and then bringing it to your
data that fit in very well with the
topic of the other paper is maybe not so
easily applied when you try to use it in
in different domains and so this talk is
really about what what do we do when we
find ourselves in that situation and so
the first thing to do is to admit we
have a problem and that problem is
search right so you know long before the
days of Google if you said search in a
computer science department right that
would be the equivalent of saying
untrackable problem unsolvable problem
right search is unsolvable and that's
true in this space too right it's very
difficult in a high dimensional space
right which is our parameter space this
triple space that we're searching for
even if you try to get fancy and use
genetic algorithms or particle swarm
optimization or really like cutting-edge
optimization techniques there's no
guarantee of a solution you might end up
with this very rugged error terrain that
really there's no way to go one
direction or another you're just
completely off in left field you know
we're close and as this space gets
larger time increases exponentially so
it's it's certainly a problem and it's
an unsolvable one however if we stop
thinking of search as a brute force of
force approach and we start to think
about how we can peek under the hood
we can use this second observation that
even when you're in a search land is
very difficult that if you can see the
data you can gain a much stronger
intuition about what's happening right
so this is an scones quartet it's very
famous right this for data sets have the
same mean standard deviation linear
regression variance and but they all
have very different shapes right it
could be outliers but when you see it
you intuitively understand it so the
idea is that instead of just wandering
randomly through this search space what
we're going to do is we're going to
steer our model selection using a visual
analytics approach right we're through
the medium of data visualization our
models communicate with us right and we
guide them into the right place and so
it's good news right because a that
keeps us in a job right there's no
automatic machine learning because if
there was we wouldn't have to have these
conferences and get to come down to
Miami from DC which is you know really
great weather so I appreciate that
but at the same time we can actually
meaningfully meaningfully influence our
workflow and so that's largely what I
want to talk about for the rest of the
talk today so I'm going to do that
through this lens of the yellow brick
library yellow brick is an unfocused
affiliated open-source project and just
full disclosure I'm one of the core
contributors and Rebecca who'll be
giving a talk tomorrow is also one of
the core contributors for yellow brick
but what I want to do is I want to start
to get into some of the visual
Diagnostics
in visual sort of tools that we can use
to look at this machine learning
workflow and it's probably simplest to
simply frame that according to the model
selection triple so let's first look at
visual feature analysis right what can
we do with visual feature analysis so in
the common case I think that we're all
fairly used to exploratory data analysis
right violin plots and box plots
histograms joint plots KT ease all that
good stuff doing EDA but when you're in
the machine learning lands right what
you're gonna end up with is 70 90
hundreds of features right and then you
get all of these mappings that you can
apply to your features to transform them
and extract different feature
representations and so it's not such a
simple EDA problem instead the question
really is what is the minimal set of
features that's going to most
meaningfully affect my model overall and
that's what feature analysis and
visually like in the machine learning
context requires so I think that the
easiest thing to do is instead of
looking at individual features we want
to look at them all at once all at a
time and so that's where these ranked
features visualizations come from so we
have ranked 1d and we have ranked 2d and
the idea is for one dimensional you take
one feature and you compare it and you
look at it right is it does it have a
uniform is it more uniform than the
other distributions is it more normally
distributed than the other distributions
right how many potential outliers or
hape axes are there and you should get
this ranked and what it does is it helps
you target in and zoom in and figure out
well what should I be creating a
histogram for what should I be creating
box plots for it so they can actually
meaningfully investigate this data you
can also think how do these features
correlate with my target variable if
you're in a supervised context right so
you can rank your features according to
mutual information or a correlation with
your target variable and so you can say
what is most predictive right given the
data set that I have now we can extend
that to two dimensions
reason that we do this is because we
note that collinearity and covariance
can be a big problem right the effect
that two features have on each other
might be a big problem in our models and
so we want to see if we can sense that
and you know true independence between
our features is is just it's not
possible right I don't think we ever
really strive for that but we want to at
least minimize the amount of
independence and so we do pairwise
ranking of our features right so instead
of a bar plot you have this heat map
right where you can compare the
correlation coefficient or the
covariance or you know the least squares
area and a error on a simple regression
the mean squared error
maybe there's nonlinear correlation so
we could look at quadratic or some other
things and what you start to note is
that when you start to do this dynamic
analysis with two different ranking
mechanisms you start to see different
areas of interest right so when we're
looking at Pearson right there's some
clear very high correlation variables
here but covariance the region of
interest is up here and so that allows
you to get a better intuition of how
those features are interacting with each
other and then you can zoom in and do
the joint plots and the different types
of analytics and exploratory data
analytics that you're used to so it's
really about filtering that high
dimensional sort of space into something
that you can meaningfully grok this
leads us to our sort of second area
which is when we're creating models
where you usually have two primary goals
right we want a generalizable model
right we don't want to over fit it but
we also want a model that's separable we
need to choose the features that create
distinct predictive regions and there
needs to be some separable 'ti and when
you're in a high dimensional space like
how do you do that with you know high
dimensions when you can only really
visualize with say seven dimensions
right maybe you have two axes maybe
three axes color size shape right you
don't have a lot of visual aids to draw
that many dimensions so how do you see
this so one very good approach from the
genomics world is to use radial
visualization so what you can do is you
can plot the features around the unit
circle around the outside of the unit
circle and then you can sort of think of
these points as dropped in the middle
and pull
to the outside based on the strength of
that feature in that direction and you
know what you can sort of see here in
this to class problem of using sensors
if a room is occupied or unoccupied you
can see that there is a clear separable
'ti between these two classes that hints
that with this feature set a binary
classifier is going to be effective at
working on this data right so this is
good news for us and with the circle I
mean technically you can fit an infinite
number of features around the circle but
you do get into some issues like you
know if two features with approximately
the same magnitude are on opposite sides
of the circle then the point won't move
right it'll just be stuck in the middle
and so by playing with this
visualization changing the order of
features trying to maximize the white
space just that dynamic behavior gives
you a lot of intuition and a lot of
feeling about what's happening inside of
the data an alternative to radio
visualization is to do things in a
horizontal fashion to unfold that circle
so that we have multiple vertical axes
right along the horizontal and our
instances are drawn as line segments
across each of them and so we're doing
the same thing in this visualization as
we were doing before we're looking for
braids or cords of connected data we can
see that you know with sio2 there appear
to be two distinct clusters of
unoccupied data but that it's more
variable with the occupy data and so you
can really get that intuition and the
same thing right reordering the axes and
filtering outliers right you can do all
of that work inside of this
visualization right it's very clear
what's happening in this but one of the
really neat things about parallel
coordinates is you can inspect the
effect of normalization we have a
problem in this visualization and this
problem also exists in our modeling and
that's that the magnitude of the unit of
co2 which is measured in parts per
million is much higher than the
magnitude of the units for relative
humidity or temperature right and in in
many models this might be a problem and
it's certainly a visual problem for us
so we can start to explore the effect
that normalization has on our data set
is it going to be like it's l1 or l2
normalization going to be effective
should be using min max been absolute
should we be using something that uses
the standard deviation in order to
normalize or do some sort of standard
standardization right these are all
options that we have in our feature
extraction but you can visually see the
effect of that and is are you still
maintaining separable 'ti when you're
applying these transformers to your data
and that intuition is is just so
important as you move forward because
you I think that people make assumptions
and a lot of those assumptions are based
on what worked before right you go with
the tools that you know it worked before
but when you have that sort of visual
instinctive ability to move forward it
gives you a much better way to sort of
find that search space and find where
you're going a little bit better now
these two techniques Radu's and parallel
coordinates are high dimensional data
visual techniques but sometimes we just
want a scatter plot and so we're going
to want to do some sort of projection
right we want to project from a high
dimensional space to a lower dimensional
space and so one common method of doing
that is pca do a principal component
analysis down to two or three components
and in this case this is unsupervised so
there's no target variable embedded into
this visualization but people who do a
lot of pca expect the by plot
representation right what is the
strength of the original features in
this component space right so you know
are these guys more associated with the
water in this model and the amount of
water in this model versus thus Plast
over here right so you can start to see
that embedded inside of your
visualization of course pca assumes a
linear relationship in the high
dimensional space and that's not always
true so we can also use manifolds and
embeddings to use similarity or distance
to embed our data from a high
dimensional space into the lower
dimensional space and these things tools
are also used as a pre-processing
technique in modeling and so you want to
see that so yellow brick has a bunch of
of manifold embedding using scikit-learn
so TCE you map iso maps lle all sorts of
stuff and so here you know with a
classification we can see that clear
separation that clear discern ability
using the manifold but we can also do
this with regression right continuous
targets as well using a heat map to see
are there clusters of high value regions
versus low value regions do we think
that a low order polynomial is actually
going to fit this data better based on
the embedding or are we gonna have to
simply turn to a nonlinear model just
because that's the only thing that we'll
be able to do right so again the
intuition guiding that model search in
that model tuning so from that sort of
feature analysis I think you put
yourself into a nice little space where
you have this really good more intuitive
better understanding of your features
certainly a better understanding than
you would if you had just like dumped
off a 36-hour search job and gotten a
table full of numbers right you have
that so the question then is like how do
we take this visual analysis and move it
into our models so the first thing is we
want to select the minimum set of
features to fit our models on right so
we know that models have a trade-off
between bias and variance error injected
due to bias and error due to variance
and that the the trade-off is based on
this idea of complexity the more
complexity you have in your model the
more over fit your model is the higher
your error data variance the simpler
model the more under fit it is the
higher your error due to bias right so
this is trade-off so adding features
adds complexity so we want the smallest
set of features that is predictive so if
many models but if your model has a co f
sundar score or a feature importances
then we can start to plot that right and
we can see the relative feature
importances what is contributing the
most information to this model and maybe
that allows us to eliminate some if you
have a two dimensional feature
importances like in logistic regression
you can see the importance to a specific
class right so maybe for class zero
the blue really this you know feature -
is the most important but all four
features are contributing to class
- right so it gives you that
understanding now you're gonna want to
do the natural thing right you're gonna
want to eliminate the lowest soar least
important features to see if that
enhances your model so but you also want
to visualize that process so this is
recursive feature elimination so at
every step we eliminate the least
informative feature and we keep doing it
until we either run out of features or
or some upper bound and if you just do
this using the automatic RF ecv that
since I could learn it's gonna tell you
that nineteen features is going to
perform the best but if you guys look at
this visualization probably you guys are
thinking well that you know that maybe
that's the best but it's really not
better than eighteen or seventeen or
twenty-one right because we look at the
variance right of the cross-validation
on these curves and if we are truly
looking for the most minimal set of
features then really ten eleven or
twelve features is going to be better
it's going to be a better model using
that metric of this minimal feature set
then the nineteen feature set is going
to be so those visual tools aid you in
figuring that out
speaking of cross-validation you can you
know you can have visual quick checks
right so our my train test splits
equally balanced inside of the class is
my cross-validation highly variable
right this is an extremely variable
cross-validation across different splits
right do I have something in my data
outliers bad data and missing data
that's causing some of my
cross-validation splits to fail right so
you can use these as simple checks then
of course you can get into the model
specific evaluations right so for
regression we have prediction error plot
and residuals plot so the prediction
error plot plots Y hat versus Y so
you're hoping that your data is normally
distributed along a 45-degree line or
you can just plot the straight-up
residuals because I don't know about you
guys but mean absolute error mean you
know square error our MSE doesn't mean a
whole lot to me right but when you look
at the error of there
Jools across your model you know you you
learn you Intuit things very quickly so
for example do we have
heteroscedasticity in my model right as
is this thing better and more variable
in one area of my target than another am
i airing higher or am i airing lower
than the target right this can
dramatically inform what model you
select depending on what your
requirements are of course we're
classifiers we can immediately just
visualize classification reports and
confusion matrices guiding your eye to
exactly the hot spots where you want to
look but it also facilitates model
comparison right it's much easier to
compare the heat map of a naivebayes
with a logistic regression or a
multi-layer perceptron than it is to
just simply compare the numbers right
like what's the difference between point
seven three and point seven four right
and sometimes that's hard to get at then
you can dive even deeper with precision
and recall and you can look at precision
recall curves both in the binary or
aggregate case macro average case or you
can look at it in the multi-class case
you can carry that on to rock a core
threshold visualizations if you're doing
binary classification or using different
types of Thresh holding for queuing
right so really get that feeling like
what is the relationship of precision
and recall in in my model you know my
professor told me that there should be
an you know a trade-off between
precision and recall but is that real or
not right in my experience sometimes
that's not real and you just have a
classifier that's just guessing right
and can you see that at work or getting
into clustering models right so looking
at the silhouette scores right do we
have well distributed you know
approximately same density clusters do
we have that bucket cluster that
everything just goes into and lots of
small clusters what's happening or we
can look at inter cluster distance maps
right so how far are this cluster
centers from each other and how many
points are in each cluster and can we
evaluate how well the clustering models
are doing
and finally visual hyper parameter
tuning which you know I'm running a
little bit low on time but we can look
at sort of the model specific hyper
parameter tuning so if we have
regularization is our l1 regularization
actually having an impact or is our
feature is just bad right
what is the Alpha that's being selected
for lasso versus elastic mat right
is this actually making a meaningful
difference or looking for the elbow in
like a K elbow visualizer but also
thinking about the time it took to fit
these models right the larger the number
of clusters the longer time the k-means
is going to take to fit and that might
be an important as important a
requirement as having dense you know
contiguous clusters inside of our model
and then of course you can get into the
validation and learning curves right do
I need more data right or do I have a
lot of redundant data using the learning
curve to find out how many instances and
is that actually impacting your model
score or for single hyper parameter
tuning we know that you know eventually
you know both train and tests scores
should go down together but at some
point we're gonna over fit and that that
training score should skyrocket and the
test scores should fall and so you know
what happens is you get this range well
I'm gonna do a grid search but I'm going
to search in this very valid range for
this particular valid curve validation
curve rather than doing this sort of
infinite search across all of my space
so hopefully with that I've convinced
you that adding these visual Diagnostics
to your your work flow really enhances
the process it steers you to the right
model and I think that potentially we
all do this in our code certainly you
know I have notebooks that have these
like 30 to 50 lines of matplotlib and
scikit-learn code in them and so I just
want to say that really what
yellow-brick contributes is this idea of
a visualizer right an estimator that
learns from data to draw all of the
visualizations that you just saw and
more right so I've showed you nothing
that wasn't in yellow brick
everything was in yellow brick and so
that sort of code that you're
continually copying and pasting you know
becomes either this right where you take
you import the visualizer you fit it and
you score it and then you poof it which
you know adds a title and a legend and
saves it to disk or makes it display
using MATLAB show or you can use the
quick method right if you just want to
one
liner to make this visualization happen
and you don't want that sort of
customization and I think that by having
this right you can immediately integrate
this into your code it's not an
afterthought anymore right you're
creating these pipelines of data loading
transformation estimator right and now
you can just add in the future
visualization and add in the model
visualization into these workflows and
when you have them at your fingertips
right that's what creates a meaningful
difference in your ability to steer
towards the best model and to make you
faster at your modeling but also more
effective at finding the most performant
predictive or correct things that
enhance your applications meaningfully
so you can go back to being that super
fireman kid when you're working with
your boss so with that sort of tour
hopefully everyone is is eager to try
this out but I just want to sort of add
another component to this and that's
that yellow brick is an open-source
project and you know honestly if you use
it we would love to hear from you guys
even on this but another one of our
goals is not only to enhance the model
selection workflow but also to be the
best place to contribute right anywhere
in the PI data community and so to do
that you know we have people we respond
quickly we engage we realize that when
you're communicating over like github
issues right that text-based
communication can be lost so we tend to
go over the top with gratitude and
positivity right just to make it clear
how welcome people are to contributing
so if you are interested in contributing
an open-source I would strongly
encourage you to consider contributing
to yellow brick but even if you're just
interested if you have an idea for a
visualizer like hey my workflow I do
this and here's my 30 lines of code I
don't have time to contribute but if you
go in and make a feature request for
that you know we will be grateful and
that will app now absolutely
meaningfully it contribute you know the
ideas and the workflow I use this
professionally in my workflow but my
workflow is different than your workflow
and so if you have an idea for something
that would make your life easier
we would absolutely love to
in yellow rec and so that's it there's
any time for questions
you got time for some questions
after once
so I have a quick question so does the
current visualizers only apply to the
models in a scalar or kind of apply to
other packages what a wonderful question
so we certainly designed this around the
concept of the estimator in cycling
however we have a contributor is being
used to extend this other libraries so
in the config package there's an example
of how you create a stats model
estimator for use in yellow-brick we
have examples of how to do this in pi
torch and in spark and we're definitely
thinking about in the future how do we
meaningfully contribute visualizations
the visualizers to those other libraries
so it's definitely on the horizon and
there's some examples now and it's
usually pretty simple right out of the
box so long as they have that
scikit-learn API you know you usually do
with just a little tweaking you can get
these things to work thank you
I think yeah thanks for the talk I know
something that keeps coming up again and
again as a big selling point for deep
neural nets is that we don't have to do
any of this feature engineering and
somehow you know we just get everything
for free with with this black box it um
I'm kind of skeptical of that idea so I
guess I'm wondering as far as with the
the bias-variance tradeoff if if you
have any any words of wisdom as far as
you know what what should I shoot for
for a dimension of my space I can
feature engineer until the cows come
home and have polynomial features and lo
you know get a very high dimensional
space and then I can do PCA or some kind
of projections and go you know back and
forth and like would you say it you know
have people looked at doing like
simulated annealing on this kind of
thing to try to get like the right
dimensional space or I guess what's a
what's a good workflow for finding that
you're not taking easy on me but it's
certainly a good question I you know I
you know I I do do deep learning but for
time series data and usually when I'm
pulling out deep learning models is for
functions that don't have a good
approximation with the more conventional
models but I will say that if
interpretability right becomes important
which it absolutely is for domain like
the medical domain and and a lot of like
domains that have risk associated with
it you really do have to have an
understanding of what your features are
and you can't just say like oh it's
these convolutions they're going into
this pool like this is you know this is
what this means and so I am certainly a
proponent of a future engineering and
and I you know my experience has been
that that is you know seventy to ninety
percent of what you're doing because you
know the reasonable defaults on the
hyper parameters are effective so long
as you have the right feature set and
then these visualizations and
visualizers enhancing that
interpretability enhancing your
understanding really give you that basis
for saying something meaningful about
about those features and you know my use
of this tool really is to figure out
like where is the complexity in this
model right where is the the place where
I can turn the knob
I can really move the needle for bias
and variance but I will assay another
place that this sort of crops up and I'm
perfectly happy using these things on
the PI torch model or or some other
model but a lot of times this actually
comes up as a defense of having to use
the deep learning model right like
listen I couldn't make you know gradient
boosting or random forests or you know
all of these like ensemble models I just
couldn't make it go on this particular
problem we haven't managed to like
distill it correctly but we do need
something now let's throw a convolution
at it and see if the convolution can
pick up something that we just can't
Intuit based on what we're working with
so non-committal answer but hopefully I
didn't make anyone upset time for one
more ok well thanks again bedroom
[Applause]
you